let f of x equal three to the negative x
minus five and g of x equals negative x
to the third minus four x squared plus x
plus six the graphs of y equals f of x
and y equals g of x are shown below and
we see them right over here this y
equals f of x is in that is in that
purplish color let me see if i can if i
can get that same
purplish color
so
that is
in that so let me underline it now
so
f of x
is
in that purplish color so y equals f of
x that's right over here in purple and
then y equals g of x that is in blue
so y equals g of x
g of x is defined right over there
y equals g of x well that is graphed in
blue and we see that they intersect at
the point a
comma b
so there's a couple of ways there's a
couple of ways to think about this we
could say that when x is equal to a
f of x and g of x equal each other or we
could say
f of a and this is coming from this
point of intersection let me draw a
little arrow here so our big arrow that
point of intersection lets us know
that f of a
f of a
is equal to
g of a
is equal to g of a
which is equal to b
g of a
they both if you input a into the
function f you're going to get b if you
input a into the function g you're going
to get b and so the point a comma b
is on both graphs both y equals g of x
and y equals f of x and so from here you
can make some interesting you could make
some interesting statements for example
you could just say well what is f of a
f of a is
3 to the negative a power minus 5
is going to be equal to what's g of a
g of a
is negative a to the third
minus 4 a squared plus a
plus 6. so you could say this and that
would be equal to
that either of those would be equal to b
all right i think we've analyzed that a
good bit so now let's actually answer
their questions
and normally i'd suggest that you look
at the questions before you actually try
to solve it but i just wanted to do this
just to really
squeeze out as much as we could out of
the information they gave us
so they tell us the value x equals a is
a solution to which of the following
equations select all that apply so the
first one is 3 to the negative x minus 5
is equal to b
well we already know that
we already know
that 3 to the negative a minus 5
3 to the negative a minus 5 is going to
be equal to b
is going to be equal to b this over here
this is equivalent to saying
f of x
f of x is equal to b and we know f of x
equals b when x equals a when x equals a
f of x is equal to b this expression is
equal to b
so we know that that first one is true
now the second one is just saying f of x
is equal to g of x
well we know that when x is equal to a
f of x is equal to g of x that f of a is
equal to g of a
because as a reminder
this right over here is our definition
for f of x
and
this over here is our definition of g of
x so this is just saying f of x equals g
of x when does that happen well that
happens when x equals a we already saw
it up here f of a is equal to g of a
they both equal b
and so both of these are going to be
equal to each other when x is equal to a
so i will check
that one
as well